Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P. Here is a
voicemail from someone who cut the show on our
broadcast affiliate a free speech TV. Now many,
some of you may know, some of you may not. Our
show is on nightly on satellite television.
That's DirecTV and Dish Network. The channel
is called Free Speech TV on DirecTV. I
believe it's Channel 348. I hope they haven't
changed the channel lineup. I think it's 348
on Dish Network. It's channel
again. I hope it hasn't changed.
Nine four one five Here is a viewer who
caught us on free speech TV and he doesn't
believe the name free speech TV for the channel
is appropriate. Take a listen to this. Buckle in.
Speaker 5: I just wanted to make sure I got the
right line. I've got a message for you that I'm
still working on, I'm writing off.
Speaker 1: This is a draft message.
Speaker 5: Bear that in mind. A
lot of information now about your
your network and. Why do you call yourself free
speech? I don't understand that you people sound
like a bunch of socialist communist idiots.
Speaker 1: Is that it? Still on the phone.
Background noise. Sir, please hang up, OK?
You know, this continues to be a funny thing.
I am criticized daily, both because one we have
sponsors and this is how, you know, I fund my
life and how my employees are paid. The fact
that the show makes money. So I'm told the show,
the show is too capitalist, it's too capitalist
to show because it is financially sustainable
and this is a socialist or communist show. Now, of
course, anyone who watches would know really the
perspective of this program is social democracy,
which is a regulated form of capitalism. We
allow markets to direct resources within many
areas, but we say in certain areas we should
be out of the market. Health care, education, OK,
you guys, you guys get it. You guys get it. But it
really is fascinating to daily. Be criticized for
being too capitalist of a show and too communistic
of a show. I don't expect that to change anytime
soon. We have such a great bonus show for you
today. Nancy Pelosi is running for reelection
and there are people writing in saying, David,
she's in her 80s. It's that's it. It's time to go.
We need a younger speaker of the House or whatever
the case may be. I have some people emailing
me saying, David, Nancy Pelosi has an opponent,
but her opponent has been accused of sexual
harassment. So I mix like, should I support
or not? I'm not really sure. Lot of questions
when it comes to the Nancy Pelosi reelection,
which we will be talking about on the bonus
show. Secondly, the FDA has stopped the use of
a particular monoclonal antibody treatment
for COVID because it doesn't seem effective
against Akron. And Florida is pushing back,
saying Now we want to use it anyway. And
Ron DeSantis sort of doesn't seem to understand
how simple math works in his defense of that
type of monoclonal antibody. We will talk about
that and we do have Olympics coming to China.
And ahead of the Olympics, there are some abrupt
and very harsh lockdowns looming in Beijing,
which we will discuss on today's bonus show
should there even be Olympics going on? We
will talk about all of it on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at Join
Pacman dot com. And this Saturday, we will have
a correspondent doing interviews of Trumpists
live at the Trump rally in Conroe, Texas. I
hope you will join me at 6:00 P East three
P West on YouTube, now on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook. We will be live in Conroe, Texas,
with a correspondent and then have the Trump
rally and the entire thing. But for today,
make sure you sign up at Join Pacman
dot com and get instant access
Unidentified: to today's bonus
show. I will see you that.